Ali is with us in Minnesota
Ali welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thank you for taking my call I
appreciate it sure your question for dr.
Jon oh yeah I have had a basically a
food addiction for 14 years since my
early teens I know it's an addictive
pattern where I overeat or and I'm at
work and I think about like this
fast-food place I'm gonna drive by on my
way home or I'm at the grocery store and
I pass by candy and that's all I can
think about and I try to be strong and
then I go to leave and I just grab you
know bags and I hide it from my husband
I've had periods of success with it
where I feel better and I'm eating
healthy and has lost weight and my
spouse they've always been so supportive
of me and encouraging and I'm the nerd
in the family you know I make the budget
and we have a pretty tight budget but I
just justify in the moment or I just
ignore it like this is this is ruining
our budget because it happened so many
times a week or our grocery trips or
whatever and I kind of just ignore them
like I'll fix it later but it's
obviously sabotages it so I'm just
wondering if you have any tips for
long-term how I can overcome this that
it's sabotaging our budget I feel just
guilt all the time so just wondering if
you had any advice on that where does
this come from this run on your family
did you have a traumatic event your
childhood no no my I mean my family was
kind of snackers and I like I mean I was
kind of made fun of growing up just
because I was a little bit heavier so
but nothing really traumatic from my
childhood okay so you can there's a
couple of different things here so
number one I want to if you were with me
I would hug you for a couple different
reasons number one I love you and I'm
glad that you called and I know this is
a hard phone call to make number two I
have a regular shame session with my
wife when she is doing the laundry and
I've got candy
for shoved in my pockets I do health for
a living right
how about this I'm gonna put you on hold
and then we're gonna catch you after the
break because this is this is an
important question I know many many
people across the country have all right
we're talking with Ally in Minnesota
John give us a quick summary what we
know so far so al you've been struggling
ever since you were in high school yes
some folks that kind of got on to you a
little bit always felt like you were a
little bit heavier than the rest and
you've just struggled to wrestle with
your eating ever since then and then you
get caught in a shame cycle you caught
in the financial cycle and you wrecked
the budget and just to just piles and
piles and piles is that about right yeah
that's great okay so here's a here's a
couple things that was talking about
number one it's one two high five you
because I'm in this with you and I've
got experiences of my family my whole
life and so I'm speaking from my own as
though we're on the same side of the
booth here food is comfortable right it
just feels all right and I want everyone
listening to this to know that it's the
same chemistry that you can hide or deal
with uncertainty deal with lack of love
for what you see in the mirror it's all
of the same pathology addiction as
addiction is addiction and so people do
the same thing with sex I do it with
drinking they do with food it's this
comfort it's this I'm not enough I'm in
a situation I'm uncomfortable and I can
make this feel better right this second
and I'm gonna deal with it again and
some people get obsessed about food the
other way right they that's their way if
that's their way of finding control is
they get obsessive about not eating
certain things or you can go on the
internet blogs and find those who are
having the keto wars and whatever it may
be but it all comes back to this idea of
comfort and this idea of I'm not
valuable and so here's the the I'd love
to hear about Dave's personal experience
too but al here's what I'm going to tell
you number one this is a good first step
of really you surrendering to it
the reality is there's going to be a
shame spin cycle that you're gonna
wrestle with the rest of your life until
you get a community around you whether
that's a traditional plan like Jenny
Craig or Weight Watchers or I think it's
noon that's out as has a lot of success
to it but getting with a group of people
and saying this is
bigger than me and I need help number
two I often find people myself included
who run from shame instead of towards
who and what they want to be and so
they're tired of feeling gross they're
tired of feeling embarrassed versus I'm
worth being healthy and I'm worth
showing up for my family hole and when I
eat well my head's clear and I sleep
better and I'm a better wife I'm a
better mom I'm a better brother I'm a
better husband and so you are worth
going towards something not just always
running away from something what's your
experience been with his Dave mmm I you
know we were talking about this with
some of our team last night a lady asked
me we have a thing after been here 90
days you sit and ask me questions for a
couple hours and I just tell stories and
one of the ladies was asking why we use
personalities
Ramzi personalities why don't we just
put out the content and I was telling
her content doesn't change people's
lives people change people's lives and
so anytime I have successfully
transformed something inside Dave Ramsey
that needed to transform it was with
human beings around me helping me to do
that and knowledge be not conformed to
this world but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind Romans 12:2 says
so the renewing of your mind is more
than just content it's more than just
facts raw facts you already know you
already know the facts but you need
humans around your group for
encouragement for accountability to bust
you to call you out to hold your arms up
in the desert all of that and to give
you the hug when you're hurting and you
also need someone that's speaking
speaking this truth over you lifting you
up and I think that's true anytime that
that's what we do in so well in the
money space with Financial Peace
University financial peace universities
you know we found that personal finances
eighty percent behavior it's only twenty
percent had knowledge so the reason that
we have gotten people out of debt where
other people talk about it is is the
power of the Chris Hogan personality
Rachel
personality or the Dave Ramsey
personality and you know i'ma bust you
cuz I love you and you know I'm gonna
make you do it and no I'm not yeah I'm
gonna tell you when it's stupid you're
gonna get the truth because nothing else
will set you free and so you got to have
some people like that around you to do
any kind of transformation that's just
you know and that's what church works
hmm you know full of imperfect people
there's hypocrites over there there's
people over there that are toxic but
there's people over there that are good
people and people that love people and
they mean well even if sometimes they're
dumb about how they do church but Church
works mmm because that pastor stands up
there and speaks and it you know it's
different than just reading that's I've
never seen somebody do something on
their own without treating one pathology
for another right so I've seen people by
themselves say I'm gonna kick this and
they get p90x or whatever the thing is
and they start working out and they get
crazy and all they've done is trade one
insecurity for another now it's not all
of my healing right they're not healed
they're just training one that might be
temporarily healthier right and then
they move to the next one the next one
the next one
you've got to surrender and that's what
this is it's just a humility saying this
is bigger than me man I'm just a
rendering in fact I cannot do this by
myself
12-steppers I'm not God yes you know I'm
powerless I'm powerless this is a burden
that's right now so Ali made her first
step today I want a high five youth
that's a hard phone call to make and not
setting up a ring of people around her
that's gonna support her and walk
alongside her she she gets to the bottom
of this it's there uh one of the is are
and eaters anonymous or uh I don't know
what you would call I don't know I know
the pay plans okay I'm here in this new
Maz an electronic it sounds like an
electronic Weight Watchers of sorts but
okay like an app right okay but food
food is art I mean you're talking we
could do a whole show on that but we are
tapping into a part of our brain
Overeaters Anonymous overreach nafse
okay we are tapping into a part of our
brain that is designed to seek these
comforts
and goodness gracious goodness gracious
it's tough when there's a fast-food
joint in every corner
that's hacking your that's hacking our
biology right there mm-hmm gotta get
people in your corner